et écoute écoute gilbert pas bien fait
de venir me voir tu penses bien si je
peux faire quelque chose pour toi je le
ferai volontiers mais quand même
réfléchi à deux fois avant de tout
plaquer parce que la banque
c'est un milieu très fermé ah oui moi
j'ai réussi à faire mon trou encore que
c'est jamais gagné mais ça a mis du
temps bon bien tu me vois maintenant
bien sûr tu mens vie mais ça n'a pas été
tout seuls et puis tu n'es pas sans
ignorer que ça demande beaucoup de deux
qualités intellectuelles
ah oui c'est qu'il faut être à ce qu'on
fonçait faut pas se tromper quand on
rend les les billets faux pas en donner
un de trop parce que à la direction ils
vous le compte
à oui on a vite fait de perdre son mois
de salaire quand on fait pas attention
moi au début que j'étais là j'ai fait
deux trois erreurs je n'ai rien gagné
pendant six mois
bon alors bien sûr ensuite j'ai fait des
progrès le métier me plaisait ça à jouer
puis on apprend des petits trucs pareils
on se on se mouille le bout des doigts
comme ça on est sûr qu'il n'y a pas deux
billets qui restent collés ensemble ça
c'est des choses qu'ils aillent plus
souvent non faut faut pas croire que
tout est rose
cela dit si tu t'intéresses à un tant
soit peu à ce que tu fais ta vie de
fêtes de progresser mois depuis cette
année je suis passé au guichet
c'est beaucoup plus agréable que de
travailler en sous sol comme je lé fais
pendant dix ans ne serait ce que pour la
santé parce qu'au sous-sol on est près
des égouts e'lara et les infiltrations
ah oui ça on peut dire que j'ai fait ce
que j'ai fait ouf quand j'ai été muté au
rez-de-chaussée surtout ça te permet
d'avoir beaucoup plus de rapport avec
les collègues surtout avec les femmes
parce qu'il ya beaucoup plus d'employés
femmes au rez-de-chaussée que au sous
sol pour sous sol il y en a pas
j'étais tout seul au sous sol alors il
ya une bien meilleure ambiance
au rez de chaussée du grâce à berthier
de berthier c'est le caissier il est
très pince-sans-rire un berger au début
que j'étais là j'ai eu droit aux
bizutages bien sûr c'est berthier qui
avait passé le mot pendant trois mois
personne m'a adressé la parole à ça ça
fait drôle moi je les prie à la bonne
parce que je savais que c'était une
blague mais ça fait loin là le père
thierry mathou fait j'ai eu droit tout
un les punaises sur le siège des longues
ça fait mal
le sel dans le café à tous les repas ça
m'a collé une distrib si gastrique
on a bien ri avec les médecins et puis
le coût du stylo qui fut fait avec une
encre spéciale
tu as l'impression que tu est haché et
puis en fin de compte ça disparaît au
bout de cinq minutes si chimiques
leberquier il m'avait pas rater j'en
avais plein mon costume neuf seulement
il a dû se faire avoir avec son encre
spéciale
elle devait être vieille ou quoi parce
que moi ça n'a pas encore disparu
c'est pas bien grave j'en ai deux des
costumes
non ça il faut se méfier avec les
blagues ce que des fois ça fait des
salades un mois ça on se fait mal notés
on a vite fait de redescendre au
sous-sol ah oui moi ça a failli
m'arrivait il se trouvait que bon une de
mes collègues m'avaient bah ouais tapé
dans l'oeil mais bon pour attirer son
attention et sur les conseils de
berthier je lui ai fait une petite
blague gentil une bêtise qu un coussin
péteur ça a jamais tué personne mais bon
dieu l'a mal pris à ça a failli tourner
au vinaigre un instant j'ai cru que au
sous-sol direct au la wii elle fricoter
avec massart le type des sicav en plus
elle avait de l'aérophagie c'est à dire
entre nous c'est de fil à un il y a que
le train qui lui a pas passer dessus
manque de chance j'étais dedans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non ça m'a donné une leçon maintenant
c'est bonjour bonsoir avec tout le monde
mais il ya une bonne ambiance
écoute gilbert c'est pas tout ça bon si
je peux faire quelque chose pour toi je
le ferai volontiers je vais essayer de
voir comment on pourrait te faire
rentrer dans la la boîte
écoute je jamais en parler je vais en
parler je sais pas à qui je vais en
parler parce que là le problème c'est
que tu me demande ça à ma mauvais moment
je ne sais pas si je suis le mieux placé
pour t&d en ce moment parce que là il se
trouve que j'envisage de prendre un
petit congé d'un an ou deux ou plus
ça s'appelle une avant préretraite
anticipée sans solde c'est un nouveau
truc social j'y ai droit parce que j'ai
été mis devant un choix que il faut que
je quitte la boîte à la suite d'une
salade bon ce qui fait je sais pas si je
suis le mieux
écoute je vais en parler je vais essayer
de magouilles et à l'est par contre
gilbert si jamais tu toi allocation tu
quittes l'épicerie saint merri tu me
fait signe non rien j'ai toujours des
relations que ça peut intéresser avec la
crise
allez allez gilbert et puis et puis bon
courage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]